[ __ ] fix my hair for this video and I
heard over there in the dark
so new trailer for the eighth movie
coming out this September it's hit the
internet I love talking about the last
trailer you guys actually more of you
watch that than I thought you would
thought I was doing with like scary ass
clown cool so now we have a new trailer
a trailer that doesn't show us much more
shows just enough more but really it's
still vague it concentrates on creepy
imagery it's what it should do there's
only one real jump scare in the entire
trailer really it's just creepy imagery
and tones what a trailer for it and a
lot of horror movies should concentrate
on very few do there's a great monologue
where the main kids like when you're a
kid you think the world revolves around
you then one day you just realize that's
not true because he's right when you're
a kid you like yeah on top of the world
let's go play when you're alone out
there in the woods you're like oh the
boogie Mans right around the corner he's
probably a clown you guys aren't afraid
of clowns yet whose will search Pogo the
clown
you're welcome Internet one thing I
noticed that Adam driver kylo Ren
looking kid on that poster the
missing-persons poster that's the same
kid bullying one of the little kids you
see in the scene you know when it shows
the balloon rise up in the backseat of
that car anyone who sees a balloon you
go missing which means goodbye everybody
I really like this penny wise man with a
lot of the Internet when they saw the
poster they were like no but he's great
he's cool he's creepy I like when he
walks towards Georgie's in the sewer and
you just he slowly walks in the frame
and a lot of his face is shadowed but
his eyes are almost glowing but just
accented the really bright it makes him
look otherworldly it makes him look
ethereal that's something you can't
fight with your fists man that's
something else and in true Stephen King
stand by me fashioned it really revolves
around the kids and child of you know
they even said like all the adults
they're all ignoring all the kids
disappearing that one doctor looks like
Edie Rooney from Ferris Bueller's Day
Off and Stephen King had a kid I was
reading it and true fashion a lot of
things just happen in life I kind of
fell off of it I need to get back on it
I want to read this before the movie
comes out from what I've read so far the
tone in this trailer is accurate through
the book which is very important the
trailer does have the greatest trailer
song trailer music of all time
my least favorite part in the trailer
was still a good part in the trailer
scene where he walks into the room with
all the clowns a bit on the nose / the
clown theme I like that Dilys because it
intrigued me the least - just roomful of
clowns that's creepy it's really creepy
to him because they're kind of being
terrorized by a clown my favorite part
is that old as textbook and there's that
drawing of Pennywise that just makes him
transcend that which is scary in the
world I just like what that one scene in
that one glimpse does for penny wise
guys in the end I thought the second
trailer was great I thought the first
trailer was great I hope it is great if
they stick the landing for this movie it
I'm hopeful as to what it could mean for
Stephen King book to movie adaptations
moving forward all right guys so the new
trailer to it have you seen it what did
you think about I put a link below if
you want to go check it out whatever you
think comment below let me know and it
does always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]